عندما كنت في باتمان بالأمس ،
قدم لي أبطالنا
العلم
علم المعركة علم أولئك الذين
يدافعون عن أوكرانيا وأوروبا والعالم
على حساب حياتهم ، طلبوا مني
إحضار هذا العلم إليك إلى الكونغرس الأمريكي
لأعضاء  مجلس
النواب والشيوخ الذين
قراراتهم يمكن أن تنقذ الملايين من الناس
لذا دع هذه القرارات تتخذ دع هذا
العلم يبقى معكم خس أيها السادة
هذا العلم هو رمز لنصرنا في
هذه الحرب
نحن نقف ونقاتل
وسننتصر لأننا متحدون  أوكرانيا أمريكا
والعالم الحر كله
أشكرك أيها
الأجنبي
شيء واحد فقط
إذا كان بإمكاني آخر شيء شكرا
جزيلا الله يحمي
قواتنا ومواطنينا الشجعان بارك الله إلى الأبد
الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية عيد ميلاد مجيد
وسنة جديدة سعيدة
أجنبية